you think yourself a hero that you would
let these criminals Go free you's don't
kill people
well I do
well he do's and he does that of course
is Dwayne Johnson he's got the title
character in his new movie It's called
Black Adam over the year the mega star
has played countless characters from The
Scorpion King to the tooth fairy but he
has never been a superhero until right
now he's bringing the Beloved DC Comics
super being Black Adam to the big screen
for the very first time we caught up
with Dwayne Johnson just the other day
in New York City ahead of the film's
World premiere
I grew up loving Superman you did I did
I love Superman and I've always been a
DC boy from boys I love Superman but I
really didn't know how I could relate to
Superman when I first saw a Black Adam
comic book and I saw the cover he looked
intense he had brown skin and he was a
superhero
I said that's my guy I want to be him
yeah
I kneel before no one Dwayne Johnson
told us he was drawn to the DC character
because of black Adam's Rich backstory
black Adam's family was enslaved and
eventually taken away from him his
powers
are not a gift
but a curse
mourn out of Rage I'm almost embarrassed
to say to you Dwayne I had no idea who
Black Adam was a lot of people didn't
know so so I shouldn't feel so bad no
don't feel bad you're part of the masses
by the way and that was one of the
things that has it required me to push
and fight for this project for almost 15
years you had to fight for it so the
studio investors as you could imagine
they only really wanted to invest in the
big-ips the Justice League Superman
Batman Wonder Woman so I started to feel
like Black Adam was being pushed to the
back burner I really didn't have any
juice at that time in my career to
really push things forward but I still
fought for it and about 10 years ago the
studio came back to me and said hey
we know you love Black Adam uh but is
there any other superheroes in the DC
world that you'd be interested in
becoming and I said no thank you but no
it has to be Black Adam you don't need
passports
[Music]
we're the Justice Society we're
introducing four other superheroes in
one movie yeah this is why I fought for
15 years and we are now going to usher
in a new era in the DC Universe
so I'm curious how hard was it for you
to wear that muscle suit
well first of all let me just say what
part was it to wear that suit with all
those muscles well wait a second you
know we've removed the muscle padding I
know you don't I know you did that's
what I'm giving me the business now this
is it that's what I think is so funny
was it hard walking around with all
those muscles Mr Johnson first of all
the first suit that they delivered to me
the first iteration it had muscle
padding so imagine me putting on a suit
with muscle padding my body with muscle
padding I look absurd I mean ridiculous
so I asked them to remove the muscle
padding plus also I was putting in a lot
of work I wanted to transform my body
for the role and we removed it and the
iteration you see on screen
is no muscle padding yeah so that's all
you so when you look at that do you go
damn I look good because that's what I
said damn you look good what did you say
when you looked at that I said I said
damn you look good I said the same thing
Johnson's multi-platform company seven
bucks Productions helped launch Black
Adam the company was co-founded by his
ex-wife Danny Garcia I think it's great
that the two of you can still work many
couples can't do that I'm thinking
working with my ex-husband no thanks but
but you two managed that very well was
that important to you well we were at
one time at a place of no thanks yeah am
I going to do it no thanks yes it was
important to us once we were able to
get through the work and the sludge of
divorce and no one signs up for it you
hate that it happens but when it does
happen you deal with it but once we
started to work through the sludge and
get to a place of marriage wasn't in our
cards
we still love each other always got each
other's backs we're going to be friends
we can cheer each other on we can cheer
each other on
we have been building a business
is the business important and that
answer was yes and I know what we have
is rare but I got to tell you it's rare
but it can be done
may he go you seem to be on the Black
Adam tour and people really are loving
this character and loving the message
that goes with it but I was watching the
other day I'm talking about the baby
that was passed up on the stage see I
didn't know whether to say this is cool
or be mortified yes but how did you feel
in that moment when you saw the baby
coming toward you what were you thinking
I was thinking oh my God that is an
infant yeah that is a fresh baby coming
right away baby yes so the context
behind that down in Mexico the love was
incredible
um and you felt it I saw a man who
caught my eye and by the way he was
about 20 feet back wow he already had
tears in his eyes and he was holding
what I thought was adult
Gail it was like baby Jesus was being
crowd surfed all the way to me by the
time that baby got to me she was just
beautiful calm Serene present
and how appropriate that the baby's a
girl because you I think you know
something about being a girl dad you've
got three wonderful daughters you've
talked about uh
about running for president I don't want
to beat a dead horse because we've heard
it and you made it clear you're not
going to do it and one of the things you
talked about was because about being a
father you like drop off but is there
anything wrong with the presidential
motorcade drop-off at school
you could do that I know I know we could
there's a lot of things that you could
do if you're president yes you could
just make it happen you can write your
own schedule Johnson already has this
title under his belt sexiest man alive
in 2016.
are you trying to get that title back
again you don't want to be president are
you campaigning to be sexiest man alive
lots of people vote for you for that too
well the truth is in my mind it's uh in
perpetuity it never goes away it's not
how it works Mr Johnson but we make up
the rules don't we yeah disrupters
some people do and while Johnson says
he's got a full plate as Daddy to Tiana
Jasmine and Simone husband to Lauren and
as a Hollywood heavyweight he still has
plans for the future there's always
something to do on the horizon I love
starting things from scratch I do love
building businesses I love bringing
businesses together and I love I do love
creating jobs for people but you don't
want to be president
I love creating jobs I love bringing
people together we're going to look back
on this interview years from now I know
I don't have a Christmas I hope you put
me wrong yeah
he doesn't he says he doesn't know and I
believe him at this particular moment
that's not what he's thinking but it's
tough guys to be a grown-ass woman and
drooling
I just stopped myself from saying Dwayne
would it be possible to touch your bicep
but I knew that human resources could be
saying Gayle King no Human Resources I
don't want that but you know I really
admire everything about him in terms of
his work ethic in terms of the job he
does the way he lives his life his
company is called seven bucks production
why because at one point that's all he
had was seven dollars to his name that's
all he had he's now if you believe the
Forbes list listed it uh he's worth 270
million dollars wow so he doing all
right he's doing okay he's doing I also
love it his commitment to this character
that's what I love I like yeah I was so
digging that he said that he'd been
trying to get this movie uh made for 15
years because he believed in the
character I can understand of course
putting the big ones out front Superman
Wonder Woman Batman but the fact that
he's stuck with it and now has delivered
it and he identified yes with the
characters there were not that many
Heroes of color superheroes of colors
and a couple others right so but he said
back then he didn't have juice he got
lots of juice he's got a lot of juice
he's a beautiful man he's very smart
human being a very exceptional guy uh he
could run for president I think he'd do
very well and that shirt was a lot of
people being born by him yeah